this vibrant city of art culture and
industry is also a treasure trove of
storied sites while you're enjoying
public art at Millennium Park in
savoring deep-dish pizza make time to
check out some of Chicago's coolest
historical spots the Chicago River runs
through the center of the city head to
the McCormick bridge house in Chicago
River Museum for piece of living history
the McCormick bridge house is one of
four on the iconic Michigan Avenue
bridge a two Decker drawbridge built in
1920 today the ornate five story bridge
house is a museum dedicated to the
city's famous movable bridges on the
west side of the city is a Chicago
landmark that played an important role
in the city's meatpacking industry the
Fulton Market district was a thriving
commercial and industrial center it was
also the site of the violent 1886
Haymarket Riot which was a significant
event in the American labor movement
today upscale restaurants swanky shops
and architectural e arresting bars
occupy the former warehouses all worth a
visit on the south side of Chicago is
Jackson Park the home of the 1893
World's Fair
their innovations such as the ferris
wheel and moving walkway made their
debut most of the fair's buildings were
temporary but to still stand today the
fair's Palace of Fine Arts is now the
home of the Museum of Science and
Industry the largest science museum in
the Western Hemisphere you can't visit
Chicago without taking a trip of its
most iconic landmark the Willis Tower
also known as the Sears Tower dominating
the Chicago skyline this a hundred and
ten story 1450 foot steel and glass
skyscraper was the tallest building in
the world for 25 years today it's the
second tallest in the Northern
Hemisphere from the hundred and third
floor Skydeck on a clear day visitors
can see sweeping views of the city and
feel the tower sway up to six inches in
the wind from shimmering skyscrapers to
world fair wonders Chicago has enough
historical treasures to keep travelers
intrigued for days
[Music]